so i really like to snack and one of my
most
favorite snacks of all time happens to
be bananas
i mean you can have them in a smoothie
with some peanut butter
on some toast in any way really and
usually like most people i just throw
away the peels after i'm done eating
but did you know that banana peels and
leaves can be used to make
all kinds of things now in fact since
over 100 billion bananas are consumed
annually around the world
scientists have developed technologies
that convert banana peels and leaves
into useful materials that are also
biodegradable
for example bananas can be used to make
shoe soles
which is truly mind-blowing so a
designer named sarah harbarth used
banana peel waste
to create a durable material called
quarry k-u-o-r-i
which is used for everything from
glasses to belts
and even phone cases and shoe soles
banana leaves are also used for making
things like
disposable tableware or containers so in
2010 a young inventor named teneth
adithya saw how banana leaves were going
to waste and developed a technology that
would preserve banana leaves for up to 3
years and these could also be used to
create biodegradable containers
so you're probably wondering why i'm
rambling so much about bananas
and as much as i love them as a snack i
personally think that it's even more
awesome that scientists and engineers
are creating useful
biodegradable materials out of them
technologies like sarah
and tennis that help reduce plastic
waste are
super great for our planet and its
biodiversity
because they prevent more plastic
microfibers from polluting our
environment
and that's the great news with science
and engineering
we humans can create technologies that
prevent ecosystem degradation
reduce pollution and improve
sustainability
so let's take a look at a couple of
other really cool examples
since i live in the sunny all year long
state of arizona
it's not uncommon to see residents
making use of solar panels here
so this kind of technology was created
to allow photons
or light particles to generate a flow of
electricity
and since it harnesses energy from the
sun this kind of electricity doesn't
require using
fossil fuels so this means that solar
panels help limit greenhouse gas
emissions
which contribute to global warming and
pose a threat to the biodiversity
present on earth right now
and even cooler for people who want a
more sleek option to use for their homes
we now have this thing called solar roof
tiles
so these are roof tiles that generate
solar energy
and isn't that so cool well technologies
like this will only continue
improving which will help us combat
climate change
and preserve biodiversity now if we
drive westwards from arizona to
california
the chances are you'll spot these huge
white windmills lining the hills
and windmills are another source of
clean energy
they are designed to harness wind and
convert it to electricity
so windmills function in a similar way
to solar panels
thanks to the people who designed them
we have another alternative to fossil
fuels
which is super great for our planet
and i could go on and on about all of
the amazing new technology that's being
created to protect the environment
even now people are developing things
like
eco-friendly vehicles buildings
household devices
even waste management systems and as you
can probably tell from all of these
unique technologies
scientists and engineers have already
found many different solutions
to try and address environmental issues
but we also have to ask
are there any drawbacks to all of these
new contributions
well there are some cons that we have to
consider
for instance since these environmental
friendly technologies
or green technologies are still
relatively new ideas
we have to do a lot of research on them
to make sure that the technology can
make a significant
impact and succeed and that we minimize
the environmental impacts that these
technologies can
have so for example solar panels can
take up a lot of space
and impact sensitive habitats so we need
to research ways to mitigate these
effects
so this requires large amounts of money
to be spent on researching and
developing these technologies
which means that companies may be less
willing to switch and pay so much for
green alternatives
and the high implementation costs also
means that
at first consumers like you and me will
probably have to pay higher
prices for these technologies compared
to traditional products
going back to our discussion on solar
panels the drawback to installing panels
at home
is usually a higher price so even those
solar panels would save homeowners money
in the long run
on electricity some consumers might not
be willing or able to pay for the higher
initial price
and last but not least some people who
work in conventional industries may go
out of business
or lose their jobs so in order for the
world to go greener
we have to figure out ways to protect
these workers and businesses
as well so clearly there are many
challenges that we have to address if we
want to
implement technology that's better for
the environment but there's plenty of
pros too
seeing how scientists and engineers can
do so much for the environment
with science and engineering we can come
up with methods to save
energy reduce pollution
conserve our planet's precious resources
even feed more people and also create
new business opportunities and jobs for
people
and that's the great thing scientists
and engineers and
thinkers around the world can use our
existing pool of knowledge
to address some of the biggest issues of
today
so to wrap up this video today we
learned that scientists and engineers
can find solutions to preserve the
environment
and make way for a better future so the
next time you have a banana
or any fruit for that matter spot solar
panels or
drive by some windmills i hope you can
reflect on the fact that these green
innovations start as
ideas so if you ever have an idea for
technology that you think can help our
environment
you should write it down it just might
be useful one day